about the fusion method Thanks because I
had some problems with yeah is it good
okay
good morning and it seems that the
organizers and they you should realize
that the organ has really been in the
hood and it is very little the
organizers organized the morning of
nostalgia here most of what I'll talk
about today so the title is fusion
method
approving little bounce obviously that's
what the workshop is about lots of the
papers that talk about our you know
before men many of you were born like
here 35 years ago on yeah so and then
then I think I always talk about papers
that are maybe only 30 years of will
make progress
this I'm basically going to read from
paper survey paper I wrote in 93 that
summarizes this method and you know the
papers related to it and how it evolved
and how it became something I believe
that the time was a very valuable tool
for proving lower bounds and somehow you
know just after the publication of this
paper you know there was nothing else
happening maybe the mistake I made this
paper was presented that they had the
80th birthday where most of the audience
were from the authorities in fact
there's a lot of I was hoping to get
them involved because there are lots of
beautiful combinatorial questions coming
out that didn't happen so anyway yeah I
decided there now to try to excite
people who really come to do lower
bounds yes the first time I heard of the
fusion method was there was a paper by
transfer of showing that the kids who
invented it didn't work
like the bug in the spoof you know no no
it's not bugging us but it's not the
statement I'll try to convince you of
Crosswhite is still useful and give you
some concrete open public so let me tell
you about this bits of nostalgia so the
the 80s were in some sense II of the
optimistic allow of lower bounds and
suddenly out of the blue lots of papers
started coming out so I'll just say well
of course it's not going to be an
exhaustive survey and many things I will
not mention but I want to mention things
that will be related to what I want to
talk about so you know around 83 both I
tie and first acts and sit sir
poof that parity is not in a cereal and
that was the big thing and of course not
just a big thing in itself free
preserves or an introduction with at
least demonstration of the power of the
randomization method
so the this class didn't exist before
this paper set was not like solving a
long-standing of a problem they
motivated it as many of you know from
understanding the polynomial hierarchy
and so on but then as both came along I
mean was the still student in Moscow and
poop the poop that clique is the
enthalpy and this was a really big deal
because this was open for you know since
chair improved in 48 earlier maybe 490
40 this master's thesis about boolean
complexity that most boolean functions
are difficult the problem of proving the
circuit law bound without an explicit
circuit lower bound was open and people
quickly realized both in the West and in
Russia that even the monotron case is
interesting and worked on it I mean
there were lot of work in this 40 years
and both would say since he pulled
admire well another paper but other
games I think he pulled also the perfect
matching
perfect magic problem is also not in
Multan privileges even bigger this
because it's a function in P it cannot
be done by Martin circuit and in this he
also inaugurated was what we call the
approximation method
what the but I did see the fusion mess
of this trying to capture and generalize
and then people got interested because
of this result what can you do with the
constant depth circuits which do have
parity gates what can't you compute with
them and I mean there was some
frustration and then somebody sent well
to us both that this is open and we
responded I thought my art will be
resolved in this job
the lots of long bounds by run time
probably not going to mention so
there'll be no confusion
so what both pulled it if you look at
majority for example not and this
already you cannot do overseas we have
no idea how to do it with runnable
frictions because there it is don't care
about on the restrictions so he showed
that these two words in the approximate
using the approximation method so
and then you know ever since this first
table
everybody got extremely excited we are
so close to proving the three is
different than me right I mean that four
circuits just have to tweak some of the
approximation method to takes care of
the not gate and there were a lot of
attempts in fact some of you know those
who get like me lots of be different and
MP papers telephony MP who are sending
papers to every there's still people who
send papers that are just based on just
like tweak this into law and for normal
tone circuits so after a few years of
attempt was both decided to put
everybody out of the misery and he wrote
another paper around 89 you know and he
really clarified the situation so he
said that first of all this approach is
it's constant even the approximation
method of this paper and he explained
that this this law bouncy are actually
the pure approximation method
and in this is said that young pure
oscillation methods they cannot prove
any non monotonic low bar so can fold as
there has basically an upper bound or
something on N squared on you know as an
upper bound on non monotone surface they
cannot prove non-muslim it is pure
approximation and but also introduces
the general automation method which can
prove title bars so it can so he didn't
tell didn't need to go to the fusion
method which is basically a fancy
version of it it was that it can be
painful
so the general form I can write non
monotone
you just need to try to do it and so
malenky comes into the picture I will
say a few words about this when III want
to elaborate a bit about this yeah I'll
explain once more let's get right but
this was a lot more results in the small
audience I'll taste it is in second and
just to prove that you know the general
approximation method can do something
yeah there please the free free to ask
questions can be it can pull tight
little bands some methods of proving
these little bounds are natural and
these will not work but yeah but the
metal extent of it yeah just give me a
few minutes just to and with the
Nostalgia here he shows another result
we applied the general approximation
method to branching programs to
non-deterministic panchik program so he
put some non-deterministic lower bound
more or less the majority requires
non-deterministic branchy program size
of majority is at least some like n
Times log log log star
is a big deal and especially because it
uses the same approximation the general
approximation method and then Mauricio
the the one that the paper that led to
the fusion method of the paper of my
which allows me along I don't remember
92 doubt the various versions we
basically try to understand las both
message our approximation method better
which is what I described as the fusion
Assad so really proved the monotron
circuit lower bound of what government
did and did more that I'll tell you
about so this is really the beginning of
this fusion method and we wrote a couple
of papers Mauricio and I around 93 one
of non monotone a story non
deterministic circuits and we wrote
another paper once pentagrams and I'll
try to explain how this is related so I
want some one of the points I want to
make is the fusion method is not just a
low bound method but it's also method to
define new computational models and to
characterize complexity classes then
program
and one thing more that I want to say
about carrot smells result if the point
of the DC story is even older and he
connected it to webs of sips earth
towards of sips of form around between
80 and maybe one is unpublished so words
of zip cellar which pulls it all
bouncing on countable surface I'll say
what they are in this he pulls the
basically the resulted and infinite
cavity cannot be done in AC zero
countable circuit which for topologies
is the Burwell sets
and he posted the other paper that
basically and be foreign P which for
topologies of services that analytic
sets are different electromagnetic cells
some may know that this result was what
got zip sell me that I've been developed
with AC $0 and this attempt I think kept
him busy with the for ten years trying
to pull trying to find a finite time a
lot of this which would be 20 so so I
was to tell you about some of these
results and I want to solve questions I
mean that shouldn't just Ocala count
which is I guess slower than I thought
the questions yet so I won't tell you
about the approximation method as was
understood from these papers and then I
want to explain how the fusion methods
if you use them and and I'll mentioned
the smallest e so for those who know the
approximation methods I hope that all of
you hear people trying to pull all bands
we have like three or four techniques
maybe I should mention I mean the system
is out other methods which I maybe
should've written down always talk about
it now which accounts when I proved the
maybe this is putting something here
like 88 now with your husband approved
and different monotone robbed and using
a different method namely that SD
connectivity is not in monotone and c1
and the reason this was interested in
despite was both without that this is a
problem in monotone P and this was
another method which is a communication
complexity method
there's complexity
donto missile and i want to mention
these methods and there are other
methods as both so to extended this
result only pulled this result using
what he calls the rank method and which
actually found recent applications in in
some of the lifting results and so on to
explain the approximation method in the
way it was presented in these papers and
then to explain in what way it's
different when you view it as a future
method and all these methods at the time
level written down well understood is
taking a progress measure in the you
know the way we will do almost all robot
defining a very clever progress measure
and see how a small circuit you know is
unable to make quick progress towards of
complicated function so these guys were
sort of bottom up roof techniques
this was more top-down push techniques
but they were both sort of dynamic with
the structure of the computation so let
me describe just how the approximation
method works and then decide the future
method in more generality and so the
idea is that you have a circuit see it's
supposed to compute some complicated
function f and the circuit is small so C
small and is complicated
you want to say that this cannot happen
and so you want to say there are too few
gates here and you know we know boolean
search it's already complex objects and
a bones idea was it you will take what
type of operations here out every can
behind or whatever operations or
mitigate take the gate seal and replace
them by simpler gate simpler to
understand gates and create an
approximate circuit zip line which is a
gate approximate
and so that is you I will to function
C&H in the circuit becomes geo page when
you look at what comes out here when you
plug DN h this is generally similar to a
she does not make too many arrows then I
will slash I probably will not say it
again counting yellows doesn't have to
be just counting how many inputs this
differs or maybe you want to put a
probability distribution all the inputs
and you know look at those that are very
interesting to this function and this
thing computes some function f fine and
you want to say that so here you make
small arrows URLs I should say you hello
but this is not at all close to the
function you want to compute so if you
make fewer hours per gate there are few
gates you get something and it's far
away from the compressed function the
original circuit could not have produced
this and this number of L sort of
completes for you you know this this
progress measure basically what you want
to say is that so when I say few else
what I mean is that G operation age is
is very close
or some distribution that they'll very
few differences according to some poor
Bettina and now I can tell you a bit
more about what happens in these two
papers just to say what of these
approximations is a monotone circuit
case in the liquor perfect matching not
in monotone P so and also approximate
end and all those were posted at all as
you can imagine and the point about this
and the point of in the in the other
result which is where that majority is
not in IC 0 so is that it's more than
just approximating the gates what you
really are doing is looking instead of
looking at all boolean functions that
are potentially computed in this in this
in the circuits right to start with
variables x1 to xn there are functions
on the boron cubes are the simple
functions and now you are trying to
compute from them complex functions so
potentially you can compute arbitrary
boolean function C once you introduce is
approximate gates they leave you in a
closed subset of the boolong cubes they
not don't allow you to step out of a set
of simple functions and this simple
functions here so the so these are the
grades I guess
the simple functions here they will just
for those remember these are just
disjunctions to all so small necessity
for these junctions of more clicks
it does maintain just demanded
everything computed in this circuit is
always a small disjunctions more clicks
and when something which does look like
that is computed you just kick it so
that it becomes one of these and then it
makes a mess and in this of course here
doll these are all binary to binary
gates here yeah so our binary but this
is sorry that em looks like [ __ ] if the
gates are I'll be sorry Shannon and so
this parity just remains parity and the
end is going to sugar publish on it in
reverse
goes to a parity of Mahlon which may be
loud but you have ends and there are few
so basically the approximation is the
simple functions are all degree
polynomial
and you remain within all the different
numbers so the question that all ask
there's a big difference between these
in many ways I mean between these two
proofs but there are both approximation
isn't the difference technical
difference is at heel and the real
difficulty and the real difficulty comes
to proving that this approximation make
few levels this is heavy combinatorics
once you've done that to see that simple
functions cannot approximate click or
perfect matching is easy it's sort of
the opposite to prove that the gates
don't make many errors very simple and
then to prove that allow the grid for
longer cannot approximate majority is
not flossing
I mean requires you know an argument so
as both does it in a certain way using
linear algebra and what small entity
does the only change in Smolinski takes
the first as is the first part of as
both edges and then he's finding another
way of showing that low degree
polynomials cannot approximate other
functions and because of this he was
able to did you want to add a small
entity you know you can do more three
gates cannot be computed by zero
circuits with all right so he changes
there he ends in the second that is to
cross-balls paper and just found a
different way to argue about this yes
today we we crop them as one one result
but that was the order and that
okay so surprising this the
approximation method gives you a
progress measure you have to still be
clever in finding it for different types
of circuits and then you argue that as
you every gate at the time does not add
much to you know to the number of
fellows does not make too many our
agenda led to something that cannot be
approximated by click cell for the side
circuit master block okay so the fusion
method which is starting with the now
with your couch now
a different view of this and this view I
should say it appears already in u.s.
both general approximation method I just
like it much better and then we sort of
understood it much better even after
doing this the defector works and it's
it says the following so this is a like
the key thing for them or the talk is
this picture so further which we are
just going to consider straight and
program that would be a review of a
circuit I want to think of it as a
sequence okay so you start with we have
some model into some operations and we
start with the straight-line programs of
the structure problem looks like over
some set of operations of operation seal
we start with the variables and these
are we can think of them with G 1 and
let them all function TL plus 1 T the
size of the circuit so we sort of assume
T is small that's what we want to
contradict if we compute some complex
complex function and we reach the
sequence of functions very important
it's a six we think of it as a sequence
of functions and then we see that we
just look at the computation on every
accepting every accepting computation so
f is some boolean function you know
everything I'm saying will work for
other domains all six to belong here
it's a very general method so we just we
can plot some one of the functions they
may be one maybe that's the one of F so
here we are going to put the big matrix
here we are going to put
the ones of F in fact we don't have to
put all of them we can take some subject
without right so this you'll see this is
a very flexible in general so if it
puppy pickles some may one of the funds
and then we see what you know what of
the last guys one-eyed is supposed to be
- then we put take another one - so many
many now you start seeing that are the
problems with the mesoderm maybe was a
problem with low bone is that this is a
very big and complex place already
exponential in the number of variables
and here is the crux of the fusion
method so this we look at this matrix
what we are trying to do is to create
fuse them into a computation
and so another computer has sequence of
length T just like before right well
this part the input part we get some
input Z and therefore Z 0 okay on the
other hand this produces a 1 this
produces the 1 and you know things that
hopefully are legal computations in that
in this program started from here you
know D I is going to be the ji operation
hi GI right well ji and so normal gates
of a computation you compute things Oh
otherwise they are just liable and you
hope that the sequence you've created
respect this okay so you're going to
generate this sequence you just met an
arbitrary way I mean with all the
freedom in the world to fuse them into
this computation so what are you going
to do it'll just going to peak so
there's this space now of functions on
you so we have all day you know look at
Omega may be a subset of all functions
on you
we take such an F feel on every column F
and apply it column-wise to this tape
okay so let me take such a function we
get to zero one sequence all right so
the question is can you hope that this
what you are trying to do will have we
will happen namely that it will create a
little computation which takes the zero
of the function without put one by which
you would have proven a contradiction
namely the T is too small to computer
right so let's see what what should
happen what are the magical properties
that I should have you can pick any of
you want right what are the magical
properties that will make this well well
there are obvious a lot of the
properties that should make it work so
one maybe the most trivial one it should
respect the old ones recto and so the
expected effects should respect the
constant so f of 0 0 is it restricts
yourself all the time the second thing
is you want to generate a zero of the
function right what you wanted the
probably I f of X I
and nevertheless gives a view of the
function okay so it's clear what I'm
writing you excise the function write
the function and now it's a function out
of the it's a function on you you know
here I always write you know the first
variable of some one inputs of the
function so you should view all of these
guys as boolean functions of U and X I
is just this one - yeah is it important
to have the same function fevicol yeah
yeah although you could imagine trying
to do something with yeah but it's
important for the way I'm going to do it
differently yeah so you want to generate
a z1 the last things you want
consistency right so what consistency
you want that the operation F commutes
with the operations of the circuit with
the gates of the circuit for the third
condition
is that Earth
the operation age
right for every word eh
enh appearing here but we don't know
what with a period we don't know what
boolean function so there are boolean
functions and we restrict them to
substitute so but you should think about
them adjust boolean function on and
variables like the Excite okay so you
know if those three things happen right
if this happen if if there is a sudden
it summarizes it if there is this such
an F F that is fine then the size gives
in these operations like everybody is
happy with this this is a plan I mean so
if you manage to do this somehow via C
could you have a probabilistic version
where you had a probability distribution
and s and the third conditional we held
with my probability of the way no I
don't know that you just and if it if it
implies the existence of an F which
satisfies all of them then sure yeah you
can attempt to publish the condiment to
see because G and H you don't know the G
and H you don't know what G and H are so
you have to have it for every unit if
you say for every day and age with
probability more than one minus one in
to tea yeah yeah so that yeah so what
you're saying is that there is a
specific way of proving the existence
yeah any any way of proving the
existence of such as is legal including
a probabilistic argument but I'll say
something why public arguments if I get
to where I want to I may say why
probably is not a good but yeah that it
makes sense that they would respect
concept though the way things have not
said but yeah by the way for those of
you that this reminds polymorphisms if
you can yeah I wish there was a more
concrete
and connection but it definitely also
this combination of physic and mind
should remind you of polymorphisms in
the study of series and the dichotomy
conjecture I'm not going to go there so
yeah doctor exist such as that's a
question so but the point is that we can
define yo two of these properties are
very easy to satisfy we just mandate
them we mandate that it preserves
constant and we Monday that it generates
a zero vector right so in fact we can
define Omega F Omega F is you know the
you know which depends on the function
is just a collection of all or less than
Omega F of zero and f of X so it's a
vector of n variables now if there was
really a circuit of safety computing it
then the surf conditions should be
violated for every F in other words the
set of test field should cover this
space of X right we must have you know
if if if size of T is size of ebbs away
size of F is at most T it means that for
every F in Omega S
there exists the age and an operation
legal operation such that F of G H is
this one
right so we can define a couple problem
we can just define the cover problem
well this is said this is the space we
want to cover Omega s and the subsets of
this space that we want to cover it with
are those sets so if you think of G H
and operation illegal operation is the
collection of all functions such as
basically satisfying this
then we can define hello and the world
depends on now on some your model of
computation matter of composition for
example includes the operation zero
taking into account and we see a little
more things you can do with that with
the model here but anyway this is just a
collection of so
they just call it the family of subjects
that I want to cover it without the
story em it's just a collection of all
these self create a boolean function
and the operation is a legal operation
in our circuit and the defines the
travel problem ID law which you know
depends on Oregon depends on this model
of on earth it's just the minimum number
of such sets that cover the universe
you know that weird you know g1 phase
one of
covering
[Music]
so we have you know we provide in this
trouble problem whose solution lower
bound the circuit size and here is their
so this air and meta theorem right so
basically so metatheorem one
it's at size and it depends on the model
of F at least Omega and you see that
Omega could have been chosen I'll talk
about it in a second
oh my god I've been chosen and okay so
you get a lower bound and maybe I should
some summer start listing the wonderful
properties of of the fusion method it's
not so important like that but you don't
have to see
[Applause]
so okay let me state the other meta
still unfilled I metatheorem I mean it's
not a serious to instantiate it so young
many methicillin like this and they are
here and I'll say more about them in a
second and the other medicine which
serves as a sort of we can clear any
clearer with every paper which was sort
of mind-blowing is that in many cases
is it most well
in some cases it was there like you get
a constant you get for some power here
but in some cases you even get a
constant power
you know just leaner very tight
we just characterizes this kind of thing
really carrot if you choose your Omega
right it can characterize the size and I
want to tell you in the timer so
everybody is clear so otherwise it
provides a little bounce that sort of
immediate from the definition sort of
the definition gives it but this you
know in lots of cases this lower bound
is tight and this should stop you know
making it really interesting so in what
sense I want to write you some
properties of diffusion methods and the
most important one to me is that it's
static
there is no circuit here they just cover
problem the kind of is absolute gates
are unordered right you know the two
right there I know there nevertheless I
give you a cover and you can put these
and all that gates together to form a
little circuit that what this means and
I want to dispel then but not quite this
spell I want to challenge you to to
check it for the various examples I'll
give I want to tell you why it's you
know what is the algorithm how do you
construct a what is a circuit
constructed from this abstract set of
gates to get anamorphic set which is
unordered and you just take it and
create from it a circuit using the same
operations that actually is older than
is completely according with the
straight-line problem for the policies
how do you take it how do you take
something like this which is GI h
operationally you know the set of safety
and you create 4 meter circuit with a
circuit or straight line program which
also has rightio polynomial in T or
really bizarre
but the answer is like lots of things in
life you don't know what to do here you
know the best strategy to start with
that this is a greedy uncle right and
the greedy algorithm works at least in
all the cases I know because it's a
metal Theo is not that but the greedy
algorithm works it's like in the
resolution will I give you a bunch of
contradictory clauses and you want to
prove it's a contradiction you want to
derive the empty clause how do you
derive the empty always start doing
everything you can are these two implies
another one now these two imply another
one then you just you know we preach
this greedy until what little you cannot
generate any more clauses so you wish
the empty clause and you get the
contradiction also here you're doing the
same thing
and it looks very bizarre because these
objects are doubly exponential in size
or maybe flip exponent so i'm not so
valued so you're going to create a
circuit out of them and the main point
is that when you're creating the circuit
you don't have to specify all these
things all you have to specify is the
value of F on them because the couple
problem tells you that an input is s of
the little public this is that F of Z
but just by again by definition F of Z
is 1 if and only if there exists an as
exist enough such that all
the GI uniforms either or di fata P R
del F of the i/o pie
that's all you have to do so all you
have to do is just solve this sales
problem it doesn't exist of Jeannette
and even though f lives in a double
triply exponential space all you have to
do is specify on these guys
well you haven't already specified in
some places right it's specified you
specify right you know that it's
specified zero on one and on the
variables and then you start looking I
mean these are you know maybe X is one
of these guys it will be maybe and then
you you just try to force it in a greedy
way try to assign values to F in a
greedy way and one of two things will
happen just like with the resolution
poof either you can keep fixing it and
you'll get a consistent values of F and
then you have proven this oh you you
know you get start and then with the
effect in the right direction
yeah you get stuck you cannot complete
it and then it must be a zero because
such an F doesn't exist that's it
and I should stress this if an or
different I put only one direction but
you should know that an F exists for one
of the function simply by taking is a
single term roll that computes the you
know if F he'll just selected the value
of the input you have which is one of
the function this would be a little
complicated okay so that's the amazing
thing and now the question is questions
about this is like kissing
right can you describe more carefully
what you mean by cover exactly what
these are all possible f-feel right and
these each one of these guys is a subset
of all possible life right so you're
trying to take a few sets like that ox
that gates if you will to cover mistake
you're not supposed to you have
succeeded fed beside the small circuit
way to say you're right all this
language this convenient loyal statement
you can try to address it in any way you
like but this second convene at Oriel
said travel problems is a finite set the
finest collection of finite subsets of
it and you ask how many of them do you
need to travel yeah so let me tell you
in the last but one that along with the
very top sentence on that word yeah
because we applied we thought of okay
maybe I didn't write it for today
they always clear right yeah yeah so
that that's all that that's all I mean
yeah I guess one thing that was
confusing me maybe we would have it my
question earlier is what is the scope of
for every GH there's not more than
functions but there are mistakes are
only to the part that you see in this
matrix so before all brain functions
zero one to the end to the other one but
if you pick you to be a small subset
then you may not see you know they would
be powerful so you just think of them
associate to you to zero yeah as you
know from your toes but is it all
functions from you it's up to you it's
up to you so you fix you and then these
are functions from you to the coma
but now when you tell you what a cover
you're allowing yourself to like pick
you're not fixing you in advance
yeah so I mean this I define it in such
a way that you can try to prove lower
bounds for various else yeah so these
are sets that have elements not in your
Omega ref but that's okay
your anyway you are trying to cover the
the sets that you use you know may not
be fully contained in Omega F so for the
path we don't use to cover it but now
I'm I okay so I have the same question
Ryan Hansel if it works for every you
every function from you to zero one
where does where to use the T is small
in this is a cover in the company the
smallest T Saturday in just in the
conclusion that half her size why don't
you just get the conclusion answer
emphasize infinite is super the price by
T because it looks like you're you
depends on T right because you is the
set of all straight line like computing
new is just a subset of the ones of the
first computer yeah but let's say I push
this sorry I want to tell you just about
that we can have a discussion about this
I just want to tell you the most
important things a relativity here so
there are lots of properties that I like
but I want to talk about the relativity
let me create a little table and
I want to just say in what cases meta
the second mentor theorem works so
you'll see how important the flexibility
of choosing what Omega is I mean one
might think that you know you're why
should you restrict yourself in Omega in
the functionality you allow yourself to
apply it might as well apply all of them
and then it's a harder cover problem and
you'll get better Loba however of course
we know it's low bound to that of M
restricting yourself help and maybe
smaller sets or nicer set way so let me
have a table here of what Omega is you
know the model you'll see what I mean by
model is provision the gates and it
characterizes the second meta c1 so
what's bellowing all these papers took
two Omega to be the monotone filters so
he's allowing only acts which are
monitor one function why it's convenient
for him and that's what he does and for
those of you know there's an analogy to
ultra filters that plays in maybe in his
mind suddenly in Tulsa first magnitude C
so in the three papers I mentioned of
was both of these are all at ball he
looks at he looks here at so I want to
say circuit model and I want to say here
and a non-deterministic blanchett
program model so the only difference
between a circuit more than and not that
amazing bunch program model is that when
you are looking at how it straight lump
old and behave I mean some of you will
get it and some of them you will not but
in the budget program model one of these
functions have to be a variable that's
the only thing that distinguish a branch
of program from a circuit you know you
take two things but one of them has to
be
variable then what you get is really a
non-deterministic particle so I thought
I don't have time to define it so I just
say but the amazing sister here is the
monotone case here is a non monotone
case and here again is case but it's a
punchy program and it shows that the
meta zero and he'll characterizes
monotone P the second result which I
mentioned is that the general
approximation method characterizes the I
mean the non uniform you can write P /
poly whatever you like and this
characterizes non-deterministic branchy
problem completely the kabul problem so
you don't lose anything by moving from
this dynamic ordered computation into
the unstructured branches problem in the
in the cosmic paper it looks--it
self-dual
that's duel she's a lot of self door
feeds of their monotone filter but if
you have for some set you get the one so
think of these columns are just
representing set anyway if you take a
vector and this F gives you one when you
complement this vector you want to get a
zero that's a self love and
illustrations up to this for good
reasons because it's easier to argue
about and here's a sort of an amazing
thing that he that he gets he shows that
if you look at non deterministic
circuits non deterministic circuits then
what you get so you know it can have one
I mean circuits but not deterministic
I should say not deterministic model is
very easy with your so a deal
not just the exes but you got a few
variables here that are sort of you know
they are not different it could be
anything but when you apply this
function alone it will give you other
non so this is like a witness it could
also give you a weakness it's very very
general in this way and it was that this
characterizes NP and in our people with
two papers are just here this is the
last last minute so you want people with
no easier we decided to look instead of
search dual filters or functions we
decided to look at a fine affine
function so here you want to look at
affine functions well the circuits have
parity gates it's very nice that you
know your function will do at least will
be sort of trivially give you one of
these commutativity conditions so if we
weathered monotone videos why why
monitor is good because the doctor to
check the old foundation you just have
to check the end condition if you take
things to be affine functions then you
don't have to check linear gates it does
have to check the end so we looked at
this and we looked at non commutative
circuits so it's very different familiar
functions it's just assign functions and
there are just exponentially many of
them as opposed to served well function
so most of our service doubly
exponential function does not commit
what do you think what class using this
was character
so the open questions you have to finish
but you have explained this I mean we
don't understand and when you look at
the other affine and you look at bunch
of programs then you again characterize
whether you characterize parity L so the
counting version of L and the final
thing I want to say again with a fine
the nice thing when you are trying to
explain how this algorithm in the second
method theorem works what is exactly the
cells problem that you are trying to
solve in building a branching program
from a knapsack collection of gates we
realize that you get a new model and is
the spam problem so it'll all just out
of there cause many of you know why it's
useful in lots of other things like
secret sharings and quantum computing
and besides world 1-9 engage and so on
but it creates a new model so let me
summarize this by saying that I believe
that because it does characterize
complexity classes it can prove lower
bounds it it's subjected to the natural
pause barrier only if you put the cover
lower bound using natural techniques but
the solving is lower boundary of the log
log log and whatever it is rob's terrain
uses Ramsey theoretic techniques and you
know they look like they go beyond that
so yeah you have a full semester full
album thank you
[Applause]
sorry some of these are bones can read
in this language yeah all of one of them
and my which is doing some and yeah so
the others are sort of me yeah
absolutely militia misspelled FFF paper
rephrases the monofin click lower bound
in this language it's very beautiful and
the second part where he looks at this
it's a result the other phrases is
result uncountable non-deterministic
circus and the analytic is different
than correlated in this language and
there you can really use words or filter
it's very convenient to use also filters
it's not a different proof in both cases
not a different process the original but
it's you know it's nice and in the case
of sips of proof it's especially nice
because sip supposes you know it's a die
Olivia diagonalization arguments not so
difficult
anyway it's the diagonalization argument
but if you do it with other filters you
know the limits it provides a sense of
limits that's much more liberal than
limits that we learn in calculus classes
move it yeah so choices Omega for the
monotony 800 bones
you wait for me to answer so for the
wanna talk you wanna don't be lower
bonds you good oh maybe all functions
right yes yes just means a little more
harder yes yeah so it's always better to
take a bigger Omega but you know you
want to you know in your own band
argument just to argue about Omega and
in some cases argue about the simplest
simpler mega is it's more convenient it
just happens to be more convenient in
the case of you know this is actual
lower bound both here and there is a
similar robot with push for branching
programs or parity parity L you simplify
Omega is a fine and you even simplified
father so in this paper that I wrote the
survey on the fusion method there that's
also in the in the abstract they are
complete combinatorial questions that
arise from their way you don't have to
think about any omegas or anything else
it just very concrete who military
questions lower bounds they will give
you circuit over in various motor
okay so let's take off you again
[Applause]